a 9-1-1 call provides insight into the
aftermath of a fraternity boxing match
which ended tragically and it's a story
the i-team first broke a week ago and
again a unlv student did pass away after
participating in that fight and the
i-team has been working to find out what
went wrong with that event and the way
it was planned the i-team's vanessa
murphy is here with a story you'll only
see on 8 news now
denise and brian witnesses tell the
i-team there were no paramedics on
standby at the fraternity boxing match
hall of fame boxing ref richard steele
tells me that's a must and we've
obtained a 9-1-1 call which confirms the
medical help that should have been at
the event wasn't there and i want to
warn our viewers this is difficult to
listen to
hi
what's the address what's the address
this 9-1-1 call reveals just how chaotic
a fraternity boxing match was when
nathan valencia needed help oh my god
here he is in red headgear the 20 year
old unlv junior participated for charity
and collapsed after his fight we are
hosting a fight night for a fraternity
charity and something happened and we're
not sure what happened in the fight that
broke out and one of the fighters
actually got injured the event was held
by the kappa sigma fraternity which is
now suspended by unlv valencia's parents
say the referee wasn't a professional
he's seen drinking what appears to be
alcohol in this video obtained by the
eye team and he frequently looks at the
judge's table valencia's parents also
point to a lack of paramedics on standby
we have nurses here but we need like
real medical the operator tells the
caller to not move valencia and to not
give him food or water there's nothing
for him to eat or drink it might make
him sick or cause further problems take
that dip get in water like lots of water
no no no do not not water no water the
caller tells the operator eight people
are in the ring with valencia while the
sahara event center is evacuated did he
get hit with something
he is the main event of the fight that
happened the last event
honestly if we're being honest i was in
vip section and then
a citizen fight kind of broke out but
everyone's fine there and then all of a
sudden he's on the floor the i-team has
obtained the call log for the november
19 incident the 9-1-1 call is picked up
at 9 41
first responders arrive eight minutes
later valencia is taken to the hospital
by 1001 that's 20 minutes after 911
picked up
33 sunrise trauma
reported nathan valencia passed away
four days later from head injuries and i
talked with nathan valencia's parents
before we aired this you guys obviously
we want to be really sensitive as we
report this i mean you can hear the
confusion give him water don't give him
water so now
this is being investigated by both the
athletic commission as well as the
university they're all doing their
review and as those investigations
happen what essentially is next we don't
have a timeline for when the review and
the investigations will be finished but
in the meantime we're trying to do our
own investigation here to figure out
what went wrong part of that is talking
to leaders asking them the questions we
did that earlier today our interview is
at eightnewsnow.com